Sabertooth becomes the god of hell and
it's amazing check this out so what this
does is this initially opens up in the
aftermath of the original trial of
Sabretooth so a little bit of History
here for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar when Jonathan Hickman first
took over the X-Men and the island of
krakowa became the home for any and all
mutants across the world that wanted to
live in a safe haven that one of the
first things gracoa had to do was
establish its security which is to say
get rid of any and all information out
there that basically deals with the
weaknesses of the X-Men how to destroy
them so on and so forth now because of
the fact that Sabretooth was at one
point part of Team X alongside Wolverine
which was basically a Black Ops wet work
team right they toppled governments and
did all kinds of crazy things that
Sabretooth is familiar with Espionage
and all kinds of stuff and so when
krakowa was established and the X-Men
started resurrecting dead mutants one of
the first mutants they resurrected was
Sabertooth and the task of Sabretooth
was to infiltrate damage control and
steal information that would was
necessary for the security of krakowa
the problem with this is that saber
tooth is saber tooth and this guy loves
to kill and so he basically killed
pretty much anybody he came across now
of course one of the rules of kakawa is
thou shall harm no human and so when
sabertooth's mission was over and he was
captured by damage control he was
initially brought before a human court
but because of the fact that krakowa is
recognized as its own country Sabretooth
could only be tried in the mutant island
of krakowa so he was taken by the X-Men
brought to krakowa put on trial by The
Choir Council found guilty of his crimes
and sentenced to Eternity in the pit and
the pit is basically just the core of
krakowa but the way this was supposed to
work if Sabretooth would quite literally
be strung up by Vines and held in a
state of suspension where he would be
aware of everything that was going on
around him but he couldn't do anything
about it it was a pretty torturous
experience the problem with this is that
somewhere along the line things seemed
to have changed that what happens is
Sabertooth actually just kind of emerges
out in the wilderness and then just like
hunts down a bear and like kills the
bear and then in the middle of this the
X-Men basically arrive now this is one
of the most saber-tooth moments ever and
I love the way this is done because this
reminds me of Sabretooth from like back
in the 80s in Marvel Comics sabertooth
in more recent years has felt like scar
son of Hulk at the end of the She-Hulk
TV show where he's supposed to be
awesome but he shows up looking like he
wears Birkenstocks and like meditates
and drinks vegetable powder mixed with
coconut water that kind of a thing he's
like the opposite of how awesome he's
supposed to be that's kind of how saber
tooth was back in the 80s man Sabretooth
was nuts this guy was intense I mean it
was it was amazing how dark and just
sadistic Sabertooth was and so when the
X-Men show up to challenge this guy
literally they're like we have to take
you in and so initially Cyclops is the
one that brings him in because Jean Gray
uses their powers to shut his mind down
but Sabertooth overcomes the telepathy
of Jean Gray he in turn slashes the face
off of Cyclops I mean like slashes his
face off right skin and everything
muscles all just hanging out and
everything but like his eyes are exposed
he then grabs his head and flashes it
towards the X-Men and incinerates them
all on the spot and then like
Nightcrawler teleports in and like tries
to rip out the heart of saber tooth and
the saber tooth like bites
Nightcrawler's head off and then pulls
Nightcrawler's hand out of his chest
which rips his heart out but because of
his healing Factor his heart just comes
back this is classic saber tooth man
this is 1980s Sabretooth it's amazing
and then he just like suddenly wakes up
in an interrogation room and he has no
idea how he got there but then like
Cipher walks in now Cipher for those of
you guys who have not been following the
X-Men Mythos for for any real measure of
time Cipher is incredibly important and
the reason why is because this guy can
speak the language of any being that
exists out there the reason why this is
so important is because the island of
krakowa is an actual sentient Island and
in fact it was at one point a mutant
that merged with a giant chunk of land
and that's how we got krakowa but this
is cool because Cipher is kind of the
go-between whenever the island of kakawa
is displeased with something that the
X-Men is doing Cipher communicates that
on behalf of the island but Cipher also
tells the island what it is that the
X-Men want to do if there's something
interesting that they need right they
need to grow this habitat or the island
needs to expand or any number of things
right the creation of the pit is a
really good example of this but Cipher
was there when Sabertooth was put on
trial but because Cypher is not
officially part of The Quiet Council he
didn't actually get a vote but what he
says is that both he and the island of
kakawa believe that saber tooth was
judged too harshly and in fact he goes
as far as to say tell me how it was you
were able to escape and the response to
Sabertooth is well if I tell you I won't
be able to do it again and so what's
funny about this is cipher says you
can't tell me how you escaped because
you never escaped you're still in the
pit and so where saber tooth like lashes
out and rips the head off of Cipher that
Cipher's head keeps talking and that's
when Sabertooth realizes it really is
all an illusion and so that's where
Cypher shows up and he makes the deal
and he says you are the only person who
has ever been confined to the pit the
only person we've ever done this with
and so instead of having you strung up
and living this life of Perpetual
suspension instead we're gonna give you
the ability to do whatever you want
within the pit you're going to be able
to reshape this reality however you want
it to be your prison can become your
safe haven you can do whatever you want
with it and so Sabertooth signs the deal
and the first thing he does is he
literally starts recreating the entirety
of this reality to allow him to
basically do whatever he wants to do he
kills Charles Xavier he kills Iron Fist
which is a really good tribute because
for those of you guys who don't know
Sabretooth first appeared in an iron
fist comic written by Chris Claremont
and then was rolled over into the X-Men
later on right he kills like wild child
any and everybody out there that he
considers to be any kind of an enemy but
what he starts to realize is that he's
thinking to too small he's thinking too
small time and So within his own mind if
you want to call it that what he ends up
doing is forming something called the
feral Council which are all basically
just different iterations of himself you
have his childlike version which had
suffered extreme abuse at the hands of
his father and was really the first
instance that you started seeing
Sabretooth becoming the psychopath that
he is now you've got his more
intelligent version and then you just
got his ferocious version right that's
why you have the boy you have the Beast
and then the intelligent version isn't
really given a name per se but you've
got him right and so what they start to
realize is they're thinking too small
that what they should be doing is
focusing more on trying to find a way to
escape and so as he starts going through
and recreating and altering this reality
that what he does is he starts elevating
himself to the point where he's killing
beings on Alternate Earth he even
becomes the leader of the star Jammers
which for those of you guys who don't
know the stargamers are kind of cool
they were like the Guardians of the
Galaxy before the Guardians of the
Galaxy as they exist now the team was
led by the father or at least the
long-lost father of Cyclops it was cool
for what it was right the star Jammers
were pretty interesting but what also
goes on here and this is what's so
fascinating What's Happening Here is
that as Sabretooth is manipulating this
reality he even imagines himself leaving
the prison and traveling back into the
real world and as he does that he starts
to manifest on the island of krakowa now
it's not really him escaping per se it's
not him leaving in a physical form
instead it's him basically manifesting
through like the trees or it's him
taking on a kind of spiritual form and
walking around but what he does is he
starts to realize he can actually escape
this place by some manner in some means
it's possible but as one of the most
darkest desires of sabertooth what he
does is he restructures the entirety of
reality and transforms it into a literal
hell and that within this place it is
non-stop torture and torment for every
single person that he despises Magneto
Mystique the X-Men the whole nine yards
he literally becomes the god of hell
it's crazy what level of power this guy
has down here now here's the funny thing
that I also want to point out this is
really a hypothesis but here's the thing
that I want to put out what Sabretooth
is experiencing here is the ability to
manipulate matter on the atomic level
he's tasted this power now what Marvel
could do and they've done this in the
past what Marvel could do is use this as
a stepping stone to start moving him up
into becoming some kind of a reality
warp it would be a stretch and you
probably have to have quite a few
stories in between but this is how that
kind of thing starts a really good
example of this is Iceman Bobby Drake
right that Iceman was just a guy who
could freeze stuff and you get that
story with Emma Frost from back in the
1990s I think it was where she took over
the body of Iceman and then realized he
has the ability to control the core of
the Earth itself and then literally shut
down the Earth freeze the whole thing
over and kill the world that's when
Marvel elevated him to becoming an Omega
Level mutant but the bigger takeaway
from that is that Bobby Drake controls
the movement of matter if you can
control how matter moves you can make it
move however you want to and removing
molecules from this object and putting
them in that object reshapes the object
it's the ability to alter the structure
of matter on the molecular level the
ability to alter reality that's
literally what Iceman could do if Marvel
ever wanted to take him in that
direction this is how that kind of stuff
happens so it's really cool to see this
sort of formation taking place but while
Sabretooth is here and it's basically
this ruler of Hell suddenly some poor
saps oh these poor bastards they
basically end up being teleported to the
pit for crimes that we will discover
later on down the line but these are all
young people with a variety of different
powers and all of whom have originated
in the X-Men Comics at different points
in time but they are some of the most
capable and arguably some of the most
powerful X-Men or at least young X-Men
that that exists within the mutant
population and they've been transported
down here to the realm of Sabretooth and
in this realm this guy is God so the
question you have to ask yourself is
what happens when a being as dark and
sadistic as Sabretooth gets his hands on
what is arguably a team of some of the
most powerful beings to exist in the
mutant population in Marvel Comics we'll
find out in a future video thank you
guys for watching and I will catch you
all later
peace